I GOT, LIKE,
30-SOMETHING FOLLOWERS.
I'M UP TO, LIKE,
15 TWEETS A DAY.
SO IF YOU WANTED TO, UM,
FOLLOW--ALL RIGHT.
- NO, NO, NO, NO!
- WHAT?
- THEY HATING ON THE HATHAWAYS.
- THEY HATING ON THE HATHAWAYS?
- THEY STRAIGHT HATING
ON ANNIE HATHAWAYS.
- THAT'S YOUR GIRL, DOG!
- I KNOW THAT'S MY GIRL, DOG.
- ANNIE HATHAWAYS
FROM DEVIL WEARS PRADAS?
- THEY HATING ON HER.
- NICHOLAS NICKLEBYS?
- STRAIGHT HATING!
- LES MISERABLES?
- LES MISERABLES!
♪ I DREAMED A DREAMS,
AND DREAMS GET DREAMED ♪
OH, MAN.
- NO, WHAT?
- WHY YOU BE HATING ON THAT?
- HOW DO YOU BE HATING
ON THE HATHAWAYS?
- I DO NOT KNOW!
- 'CAUSE THAT'S YOUR GIRL, DOG!
- THAT'S MY GIRL WITH THE--
I'VE BEEN ROLLING
WITH THE HATHAWAYS
SINCE PRINCESS DIARIES!
- SHH.
YOU WAS THERE SINCE DAY ONE!
- MAN, YOU KNOW I BE LOVING ME
SOME PRINCESS DIARIES 2:
THE ROYAL ENGAGEMENT!
- YOU GOT THE BLU-RAY!
- AND I GOT THAT ON DVD
AND LASER DISC AND VHS, MAN.
- PFFT.
- RACHEL GETTING MARRIED THOUGH.
- WHAT? UH-UH.
- MM-MM.
- UH-UH. UH-UH.
- RACHEL GETTING MARRIED.
- RACHEL GETTING MARRIED,
THOUGH?
THOUGH.
- YO, DO YOU LOVE
ANNE HATHAWAYS?
- I DO!
- COME ON.
[both scatting wedding hymn]
both: HATHAWAYS!
- COME ON, MAN.
AND THE OSCAR GOES TO...
- ANNIE HATHAWAYS.
CRACKHEAD KILLED HER BROTHER!
- THAT'S RIGHT.
both: COME ON.
- BROKEN BACK.
- OKAY, BROKEN BACKS.
BROKEN BACKS.
- TALKING ABOUT
BROKEN BACK MOUNTAIN.
- THAT'S RIGHT.
BROKEN BACKS, DOG!
I'M MARRIED
TO JAKE JIGGLING-HALLS.
- UH, GIGGLING-THALLS?
- THANK YOU.
I STAND CORRECTED.
SO WAIT. YOU KNOW WHAT?
- I DIDN'T LIKE THAT ONE.
- THAT WAS NOT
MY [bleep], THOUGH.
BROKEN BACKS
WAS NOT MY [bleep].
- BUT SHE WAS GOOD IN THAT.
- SHE WAS GOOD.
OH, PLAY THAT CONFIDENT
TEXAS BUSINESSWOMAN.
TALK ABOUT STRAIGHT UP,
"YOU KNOW WHAT?
I'M STRUGGLING
WITH MY HUSBAND'S SEXUALITY."
- SHE KEPT HER INTEGRITY
AT THE SAME TIME
AS SHOWING HER BREASTESES.
- THAT'S A DELICATE BALANCE.
both:
THAT'S A DELICATE BALANCE.
- WHY WAS YOU HATING
ON THE HATHAWAYS?
- BUT WHY WOULD YOU BE HATING
- CONFIDENT WOMAN IN HOLLYWOOD
WHOSE SOLE CHARACTER FLAW
IS THAT SHE CARES TOO MUCH!
- SHE CARES TOO MUCH!
- IT'S THAT SHE CARES TOO MUCH!
- YEAH, SHE CARE TOO MUCH!
- COME ON!
- YOU KNOW
WHO THEY NEVER BE HATING ON?
- WHO'S THAT, DOG?
- SANDRA BULLOCKSIES.
- SHE'S MY GIRL,
AND THEY NEVER BE HATING
ON HER.
- THAT'S YOUR GIRL RIGHT THERE.
STRAIGHT UP THERE.
SANDRA BULLOCKSIES
YOUR GIRL RIGHT THERE.
STRAIGHT UP.
- DO YOU KNOW WHO SHOULD
DO A MOVIE TOGETHER, THOUGH?
- BUT WHO IS THAT, DOG?
- BULLOCKSIES AND HATHAWAYS!
- YOU TALKING
ABOUT SOME HATHAWAY
AND SOME BULLOCKSIES?
- NO!
I'M TALKING
ABOUT SOME BULLOCKSIES
AND SOME HATHAWAYS!
- LET ME JUST EXPLAIN
WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT, THOUGH.
I'M TALKING ABOUT SOME HATHAWAYS
AND SOME BULLOCKSIES.
NO, YOU RIGHT.
both: BULLOCKSIES.
HATHAWAYS.
THAT WOULD BE MY [bleep]!
- OH.
- OH, YOU GOOD?
- YEAH, I-I'M GOOD.
- I THOUGHT SOMETHING
WAS GONNA...
- ME TOO. SO--
- HAPPEN FOR A SECOND THERE.
- FIGURED WE WOULD TRANSFORM
IN SOME WAY,
SHAPE, OR FORM.
OKAY.
- THAT WOULD BE MY [bleep]!
both:
THAT WOULD BE MY [bleep]!
[thunder]
[laughter and applause]